foreign
in the 1953 science fiction film the
beast from 20 000 fathoms a giant
monster attacks New York City as giant
monsters are known to do
while the film's plot isn't particularly
noteworthy one element that stands out
comes about halfway through the film
when a group of scientists try to figure
out the evolutionary history of the
mysterious creature our interest in the
theoretical biology of unknown life
forms hasn't gone anywhere for the past
Century stories of Cryptids like Bigfoot
or the Loch Ness monster have continued
to Fascinate and while these creatures
likely don't exist that doesn't mean it
isn't Fun to speculate on their biology
enter cryptism logicon a book that
imagines evolutionary backstories for
legendary creatures created by renowned
paleontologist Darren Nash alongside
Channel Mainstays cm kosman and John
Conway the volume is so detailed that I
had to know more
so where did the idea of writing a book
on the speculative biology of Cryptids
come from
the idea did originate with me I said
well there's all these creatures in
cryptos orgy that are posited as
potentially real animals but are
essentially exercises in speculative
zoology the cryptozoological literature
has got this extraordinary amount of
speculation about if these creatures are
real what are they like what's their
evolutionary history
so for this entry into the archive we'll
investigate the imagined biology of the
world's most famous Cryptids and you can
purchase the book and follow and support
the creators using links in the
description below now let's explore the
creatures of crypto zoologicon
we'll start with the celebrities of the
Cryptid World The Hairy humanoids best
known for their alleged footprints
the most familiar Cryptids are Bigfoot
Yeti every culture in the world that we
know about has Legends of wild people of
some kind I think it's a good case to be
made that that's a human-wide
expectation I think it's already
embedded within our cultural landscape
Bigfoot in the yeti may be a
socio-cultural phenomenon rather than an
Undiscovered primate species but if we
were to Envision their evolutionary
history an interesting challenge emerges
just how do these speculative hominids
relate to us and to each other the
crypto zoologicon team solution is to
imagine Bigfoot in the yeti as large
herbivorous Eeps more closely related to
orangutans than humans the project
imagines the yeti in Bigfoot to be close
cousins related subspecies possessing
different adaptations for their
respective environments in fact the
crypto zoologicon team created an entire
phylogenetic tree to show how these
lineages connect not just to each other
but to other lesser-known ape Cryptids
from around the world the orang pen deck
for example are smaller red-coated
humanoids from Sumatran folklore which
the team pictures as another member of
this forgotten branch of the primate
family tree but this is just scratching
the surface of the team's creativity
another famous yet far more unusual
Cryptid comes from the folklore of the
Americas the chupacabra is a fabled
creature said to drain the blood from
livestock like goats what exactly the
chupacabra is supposed to look like
varies a lot between alleged eyewitness
descriptions from a dog-like creature to
more of a bloodthirsty kangaroo
if the chupacabra were a real animal the
team imagines it would be a semi-bipedal
nocturnal Predator yet unexpectedly the
team pictures the chupacabra is a giant
relative of the opossum the opossum
lineage might not seem like the one most
likely to produce a bloodthirsty Terror
of the night but in fact the strong jaws
and formidable upper canines of opossums
would require little evolutionary
modification to produce a large-bodied
predator
if such a creature did roam the Americas
one would have to be extra careful after
the sun went down
when we think about reptilian beasts
lurking below the water many of us might
think of the Loch Ness monster but off
the coast of New Zealand in 1977 a
Japanese fishing trawler reportedly
found something else
the zoyu meru carcass was a corpse the
fishing crew accidentally hauled in from
the deep sea which many speculated was
some kind of sea monster thorough
analysis of amino acids in The Corpse's
muscle tissue later indicated it was in
fact the carcass of a basking shark
which had decomposed in a peculiar
manner but what if that wasn't the case
so what was the team's thought process
behind reimagining the zoyu meru
creature we are thinking if we run with
this zoyamuru creature as if it is an
actual Cryptid and a new kind of animal
then what would it look like and the
carcass of course is a decomposing car
because he's not pretty it's got like
strands of decomposing flesh hanging off
it so we thought wouldn't it be fun to
imagine that that is the actual
creature's real appearance it's some
kind of like hideous zombie deep water
creature with sort of Tassels and
strands hanging off its body the sort of
thing that we do know of in the real
world thanks to Peculiar deep sea fishes
versus you know deep sea anglerfishes
and whatnot
the team goes on to speculate that
perhaps the lumps of the zoyumaru
creature could help it mimic the lumpy
muddy terrain of the sea floor or even
mimic a rotted corpse to appear less
appetizing to predators in either case
it's fun to speculate on even if the
real explanation behind the carcass is
less spectacular
according to Aboriginal mythology the
Wilderness of Southeastern Australia is
home to a fearsome creature known as the
bunyip in amorphous water monster the
bunyip is often described as a flippered
amphibious animal that attacks from the
water while some depictions of the
bunyip are quite Fantastical others are
more grounded to the point that some
have theorized that the bunyip might be
a cultural memory of a large extinct
Australian marsupial of which there are
several other theories suggest that the
bunyip actually comes from sightings of
animals like the Platypus which frankly
does look quite a bit like a mythical
creature but if the bunyip were an
Undiscovered animal the team's concept
for the creature is a semi-aquatic
marsupial the idea of an aquatic
marsupial presents an interesting
challenge as marsupials give birth to
underdeveloped babies that they raise in
a pouch as a solution the the team
proposes that like the unusual South
American Water possum the bunyip's pouch
has a watertight seal such an adaptation
could allow the bunyip to thrive in
aquatic environments something that real
Australian marsupials have struggled to
do
the tale of the Beast of javudon is one
of the most genuinely interesting and
intriguing of cryptozoological mysteries
between 1764 and 1767 in Southeastern
France over 70 people seemingly perished
from encounters with an enormous
wolf-like Beast the Beast quickly became
legendary in multiple large wolves
believed to be responsible for the
beast's attacks were slain during that
time allegedly a rogue hyena was
eventually caught and killed as well as
unlikely as that might sound the
animal's pelt was documented going on
display in Paris years later confirming
that an escaped hyena really did briefly
roam the French Countryside in view of
all this it seems the attacks came from
numerous culprits the stories of which
were inadvertently combined to form the
legend but now let's imagine that the
Beast of javudon was a sing single
undocumented monster taking inspiration
from reports that the Beast had curved
claws in a long slender tail the team
interprets the creature not as a wolf or
hyena but a type of giant mustelid
mustolids are a family of carnivorous
mammals that includes otters ferrets and
Wolverines this version of the Beast of
javudon would be an entirely new subset
of the mustelid family and would make
the European Countryside far more
dangerous
thanks in part to a somewhat notorious
faux documentary that aired on the
Discovery Channel in 2013. the idea that
a certain bus size prehistoric shark
could still be living undetected has
become a popular one
given your expertise as a paleontologist
just how outlandish is it that the
Megalodon survived into the modern era
there's no chance that it's still alive
it's not really appreciated how poor the
case is lots of data on the position of
Megalodon teeth in the fossil record has
shown that this shark did not survive
into the Holocene the modern era and it
probably didn't even definitely solve
into the pleistocene most of them have
turned out to be older than about two
million years old way way way before the
the modern era yet in a speculative
parallel universe where the Megalodon
did still swim in the Seas what would it
look like in order for a whale eating
shark to remain elusive it would likely
have to have evolved into a deep water
fish that lurks in undersea Canyons the
team suggests that this new Abyssal
Megalodon would be a ghostly white and
would be a separate species from its
pliocene ancestors such Terrors of the
deep would certainly make swimming more
nerve-wracking
on the Indonesian island of java a demon
is said to fly through the mountains on
leathery Wings infrequent reports from
the 1920s describe the ahuel a bat-like
terror with a massive wingspan in the
face of a primate while it's unlikely
such an organism ever existed the
concept of a giant bat monster isn't too
hard to reimagine as something more
biologically plausible the team
envisions the ahul as an unknown bat
lineage even larger than the fox face
Mega bats a Burly Predator the Hool is
able to walk bipedally on the ground
bringing prey to the forest floor after
tackling them in the air in aggressive
carnivore this creature possesses a
short snout that vaguely resembles the
face of a monkey all in all it's an
astute reimagining of a rather unlikely
life form
according to Folklore hidden deep in the
misty Moors of Scotland lurks a spectral
horse kilpie is an old Scottish name for
an equine monster said to dwell within
deep Lakes hoping to drag unsuspecting
travelers to a watery grave since horses
aren't amphibious the Kelpie is a
challenging creature to reimagine as a
plausible life form but there are
several hoofed mammal species like
wildebeest or water buffalo that do
routinely wallow in rivers and lakes
more surprisingly there are even some
species of chevrotain bizarre animals
also known as mouse deer that are known
to walk underwater along the bottom of
pools so the team imagines the Kelpie as
giant relatives of the Chevrolet that
possess thick manes and cloven hooves
that make them look superficially
horse-like from a distance reimagining
Kelpies as semi-aquatic chevertains
could also explain their occasional
carnivorous behavior from the Legends as
shiv retains or omnivores the team
imagines the Kelpie possess fang-like
teeth to drag prey into the water which
would on occasion include humans
in the Lee koala River Region of the
Congo Basin a reptile-like creature with
plates on its back supposedly lurks and
the swamp upon hearing of this
creature's description some Outsiders
interpreted the beast called the mumbilu
membilu membilu as some kind of aquatic
stegosaur that had miraculously survived
the KT Extinction event while this would
be cool it's quite the leap to make and
even very speculative reimagining the
team found the stegosaur explanation to
be too far-fetched
if you're gonna take seriously the idea
this is a real animal then stegosaurus
you know way down the list of things you
could class as probable and so four
cryptos or Lodge gone we thought wait a
minute there's this group of relatively
large tropical African fish that have
some amphibious capability and have
dorsal finlets uh forming like a single
line along the top of the body they're
called the beshears so let's have some
fun with this what about the idea that
billion is made gigantic amphibious
unusual [ __ ] here the team imagines
that this speculative life form uses its
massive spines to send signals to other
members of its kind and can climber onto
land using its muscular front flippers
it's still a pretty extreme concept for
an animal but less so than an asteroid
proof aquatic stegosaurus
wherever a dark Street winds through the
countryside in the United States the
goat man is supposedly on the prowl as
the jokey nature of the name might
suggest the goat man is for the most
part not taken seriously and is just
meant to be a fun yet spooky urban
legend exactly what the goat man is in
what it looks like varies between
stories and is generally just meant to
be a vaguely humanoid creature that
prowls around in the dark but playing
the speculative game once more the team
redesigns the goat man as a large
human-sized North American monkey
uniquely adapted for Rapid bipedal
running they picture these creatures as
highly elusive able to rapidly Sprint
away from danger hence the confusion
over their appearance it would certainly
be a shock to encounter such creatures
especially since the team imagines
they'd be capable of ferocious
aggression when the need arises
in the mountains of New Guinea a report
from the 1930s describes a creature from
another age stunt pilot and
self-described adventurer Charles Miller
claims he witnessed a towering Beast
with a long neck and tail emerge from
the forest which he believed to be a
lost Mesozoic dinosaur while the concept
of dinosaurs surviving in a Lost Valley
somewhere was a bit of a cultural
phenomenon at the time the report wasn't
believed and years later Miller all but
admitted he made the encounter up if
Miller's monster was a real life form
the crypto zoologicon team imagines that
like member
it wouldn't be a lost dinosaur but
rather a dinosaur-like offshoot of a
modern genus taking inspiration from the
Galapagos tortoise they picture the
creature to be a turtle offshoot that
evolved into a giraffe like herbivore in
an isolated island environment while not
quite a dinosaur or a giant super neck
tortoise would be quite the sight to
behold
arguably one of the most fascinating
episodes in cryptozoological history
comes from the Colombian Venezuelan
Border in 1929. here Swiss geologist
Francois delois took a creepy photo of a
deceased primate he claimed was an
Undiscovered species the infamous photo
was treated with immediate skepticism
and has been largely proven to be a
white-faced spider monkey that delois
propped up to make it appear larger than
it actually was but what if the deloy's
ape had been a real animal the team
envisions a primate that split off from
spider monkeys during the pleistocene
becoming large bipedal Ground Dwellers
in our timeline this lineage includes
some of the most intelligent and
adaptable primates so it follows that
the larger delois ape would be
particularly smart perhaps routinely
using Tools in seeming almost human-like
when forging and using weapons
one of my absolute favorite aquatic
Cryptids supposedly dwells in the waters
of the North Atlantic the long-necked
seal most reports come from the 18th
century and describe seal-like creatures
with peculiar elongated necks the scarce
sightings of this creature seem to come
from individuals who were unfamiliar
with the appearance of sea lions the
team envisions long neck seals as a
genus of pinnipeds that fill a unique
ecological niche instead of pursuing
fish in the Open Water these creatures
munch on slow-moving sea cucumbers and
starfish on the abyssal plain their
nostrils have evolved into protruding
breathing snorkels meaning that unlike
common seals long neck seals never have
to come ashore
off the coast of Alaska another aquatic
Cryptid comes in the form of the
teaseruk a Sleek aquatic monster it's
possible this creature comes from real
sightings of leopard seals although some
Legends describe it as having horns
faced with such a strange mix of
features the team has come up with an
ingenious speculative solution they
imagined the teaseruk to be
extraordinarily large pinnipeds perhaps
related to their version of long neck
seals they envisioned this creature
would eat small marine mammals and even
the occasional human swimmer instead of
horns this teaseruk possesses two soft
retractable structures on the top of its
head which they inflate when displaying
to potential mates or Rivals it's an
unusual feature but when one is trying
to imagine a plausible version of a seal
with horns one has to get creative
and to conclude or experiment one of the
most bizarre Cryptids ever conceived
comes from the western United States in
the form of hoop snakes this creature
comes from tall tales in the 1700s which
describe a snake that can travel rapidly
by grabbing its tail in its mouth to
form a hoop and roll like a living wheel
allegedly hoop snakes would Race Across
the countryside in Pursuit Of Prey as
you can imagine this sort of snake is
quite the challenge to redesign as a
more realistic creature though not
entirely impossible as unlikely as it
might sound Golden Wheel spiders do curl
themselves into a bowl and roll down
sand dunes to escape Predators they
don't form Hoops like the eponymous
snake but they at least show that there
is a precedent for turning yourself into
a round thing and rolling away at high
speeds the team envisions a hoop snake
that has evolved in much the same way
the Imagine creature's musculature is
specialized around supporting a wheel
shape and its sturdy bones are able to
endure the bumps of the road furthermore
the interior of its mouth is heavily
keratinized and perfectly shaped to
latch onto its tail with a thick
keratinous flap sealing the tail in
place the western United States would
certainly be more perilous if deadly
snakes could roll around at high speeds
but I still find myself wishing I lived
in a world with hoop snakes
foreign but according to Darren Nash
himself just because a creature likely
doesn't exist it doesn't mean it can't
tell us something about ourselves and
our cultures I think Krypton has an
enormous potential to teach us a lot
about how we behave people have these
particular kinds of creatures as sort of
fixtures of the imagination you go to a
big deep Cold Lake you look in the water
there's automatically the idea even if
you see absolutely nothing there's the
idea that there could be some giant
scary and predatory monster in the lake
that is a that's like a fixture of our
culture our species as a whole we often
seem to have the same kind of creatures
uh for me it's like cryptos orgy is is
uh is culture is like firmly embedded
within cultures whether those creatures
exist or not
a tremendous thank you to Darren Nash
for speaking to me about cryptozoology
once again you can purchase cryptozo
logicon to see more reimagined Cryptids
and follow and support the creators
using the links in the description below
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign